voilà continue allez regarde où tu vas
ce samedi matin pas de grasse matinée
pour les enfants
accompagné de leurs parents ils sont
plus d'une dizaine à s'être déplacés au
centre aqualudique castellia à Maurepas
pour assister à des cours de natation
l'objectif évaluer leur niveau
d'autonomie dans l'eau effectivement il
y a toujours une crainte quand on tourne
le dos ne serait-ce qu'un instant de se
dire
avant septembre ou avant six ans est-ce
que tout va bien est-ce que j'ai pas été
une attentif trop longtemps c'est le
moyen de faire le test et de voir si on
peut la laisser un peu en autonomie sans
sans être vraiment derrière à 100% et
voilà durant l'été 2021 près de 1500
noyades accidentelles ont été recensés
en France pour ce week-end dédié à la
lutte contre la noyade des maîtres
nageurs proposent d'évaluer gratuitement
l'autonomie des enfants dans l'eau trois
tests nationaux sont proposés en
fonction de leur niveau
vert le savoir nager en sécurité ça pour
nous le niveau bleu et le savoir nager
en milieu naturel ça va être plutôt le
niveau rouge donc ça permet aussi pour
nous mettre majeur de savoir en
septembre leur niveau de base et pouvoir
progresser et les faire avancer
justement dans l'objectif vers un niveau
rouge et vers un
natation correcte
nager la tête sous l'eau restez immobile
toute une panoplie de tests sont pensées
par les maîtres nageurs pour évaluer les
enfants c'était bien j'ai trouvé que je
m'étais bien appliqué
que maintenant je sais mieux faire un
peu de piscine j'ai appris les trolls de
mer
j'ai juste au bout et j'ai mis la tête
sous l'eau en passant parce que ça
j'arrivais pas encore à l'issue de cette
séance chaque enfant repart avec un
diplôme et des axes d'amélioration pour
être comme un poisson dans l'eau